what's something that your kids don't
know about you that would make them kind
of embarrassed I have a sex
life do you want to do you want to get
into that a little
more they watch
you hey just so you know what are your
kidss names Tyler Megan and Britney hey
Tyler Megan and Britney your mom that's
basically what she just said she's doing
yeah your mom's doing it what's the
craziest line go for you one of your
kids has told you that they don't have a
sex
life so how did you find out that they
were having s I heard
it you heard it coming from the room my
son most especially yes he was a bit of
a
man and is he the one who's making all
the noise mhm yeah oh and the the other
yeah yeah does he have a go-to
noise sh